on va y retourner qu'est-ce que tu veux que je
fasse ta fille de 15 ans Oh qu'est-ce que tu fous
après que ta [ __ ] se soit fait gifler comme une chienne
avec le premier on a apporté quelque chose de
vraiment original et frais et assez
choquant et on a pris ça  potentiel
et l'ont poussé d'un cran plus haut, ils
peuvent porter des costumes mais ce n'est pas Halloween, ce
sont de vrais super-héros, cela donne
l'impression que
quelque chose d'épique arrive à nouveau
moi et Hit Girl, nous nous entraînons tous les jours,
il y avait de plus en plus de gens
nous rejoindre tous les soirs Colonel stars and stripes
soutenant le devoir c'est la
plus grande chose que j'aie jamais vue Dave
dans son monde la vie est de severac
fantasy essayer de s'amuser
sinon soutenir hey girl est toujours
totalement badass et le plus cool de 16
ans  vous vous rencontrerez probablement un jour si je
vous surprends à voler à nouveau un shitburger Je vais
aller en Arabie Saoudite sur ton cul et
te couper la main promets-moi que tu n'aimes pas
les bateaux en feu un monde pour
les super-héros
où obtiennent-ils une charge de  moi lu mademoiselle
il n'est plus je suis passé du
côté obscur je vais faire payer les invités pour ce qu'il a
fait à ma mort
dorénavant je serai connu comme cet
[ __ ] je ne t'appelle pas ça
oublie ça ils ont commencé  un fou donc
tout le monde le fait [ __ ] de ce qu'ils
ne savent pas c'est que c'est dangereux de rouler les mains
dans les airs
et de faire le registre et de ne
rien faire de stupide les gens se blessent réellement
et il y a des conséquences pour ce que tu fais me
promets que tu le feras  ne jamais s'habiller
dans cette tenue le premier film qu'ils ont
créé ces alter vous les gars kick ass
hey girl
mais ils n'avaient toujours pas répondu à cette
question plus large de Qui suis-je vraiment qu'est-
ce qu'il y a derrière ce masque peut-être qu'elle
n'a jamais embrassé un garçon peut-être que je vais Jam mon
levez votre snatch vous ne vous attendiez pas
du début à la fin juste beaucoup d'
intensité humour violence donnez-moi une
balade amusante il n'y a pas de place pour les punks et les costumes
juste de vrais héros qui peuvent vraiment botter le cul
vous ramasse à nouveau dans le mix
alors c'est juste  genre de suce tu es le
jeu de visage sur les [ __ ] juste
amusant et divertissant content que tu aies
sorti ça de ton système comme Batman et Robin
d'accord Robin souhaite qu'il soit moi